hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control cm .l2 Dash 3.4.7 restrict
disabler prevent the use of
non-essential programs functions ports
protocols and services let's get into it
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all the cmmc
dfars and nist sp80171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance solution where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmmc control
cm.l2-3.4.7 restrict disabler prevent
the use of non-essential programs
functions ports protocols and services
uh hey look same basic principle about
not letting people access files and
systems they don't need access to to
perform their currently assigned job
duties let's extend it all right let's
also make sure that we eliminate access
to any other capabilities that they have
right so now it's not just accessing you
know files and things like that uh now
we want to just straight up just we want
to disable their ability to do dumb
things like that's the really the best
way to explain it all right don't let
them have
bit torrent ports open on the network
they don't need it they don't you're
paying for the bandwidth shut it down
all right fastest way to get in trouble
is leave your front door open at night
maybe you leave some milk and cookies
for the bad guys to come in at the front
door right it only works one time a year
guys that's Christmas and you have to
leave by the chimney anyway uh the point
is is again we just really want to be
able to restrict and disable anything uh
you know that would allow someone to get
in and do bad things or our people to
get out and do dumb things that's
probably the best way to say it all
right so let's check out what the
assessors are looking for on this one
how to make them happy
first assessment Point determine if
essential programs are defined oh we got
to Define programs yes essential
programs are defined by the IT team uh
only the IT team can allow program
installation right so that's the first
thing if you're an I.T director okay the
first thing you do is you get in there
and you stop people from installing all
kinds of Rogue software okay sorry if
you're an I.T director to be with your
company's big enough that your people
shouldn't just be installing things they
need to be restricted and you need to
know what's going on all right so
essential programs are defined in the
Baseline configuration documentation
right and you have that because you have
a system security plan and you
we have that right of course you do so
again Baseline configuration is going to
determine what the what the programs are
that are allowed you're going to
restrict everything else and then you're
going to allow by exception anything
else coming in so that's a great way to
do it all right determine if use of
non-essential programs is defined uh
non-essential programs are not allowed
to be installed on organizational
systems uh you want to deny all of those
so here's a great example okay
non-essential programs you know you may
do this with several different
methodologies right you may do it by
restricting by individual program name
we probably don't really need a whole
bunch of computer games on here we
certainly want to eliminate things like
BitTorrent you know known BitTorrent
programs uh you know things like that
again whatever is normal but you know it
Candy Crush you probably don't need
Candy Crush except for the CEO he can go
into a DMZ and do whatever he wants but
everybody else no Candy Crush so again
they want you to prove uh you know via
VIA showing them you know firewall you
know configurations or whatever it is
that non-essential programs are defined
maybe it's Group Policy however you're
restricting those those those programs
are being installed third assessment
Point determine if the use of
non-essential programs is restricted
okay disabled or prevented as defined
non-essential programs are not allowed
to be installed on organizational
systems uh deny all permit by exception
that is how we would set it up if we
were involved but again the idea really
is is that you know hopefully you've got
some group policy or just general some
kind of policy in place lots and lots of
ways to do it
um you know again
we don't have a sponsorship so we'll
talk about any particular software
Solutions but there's lots of stuff out
there that allows for uh software to be
restricted on installation
but if you happen to be called VMware
and you want to sponsor one of our
videos we can definitely talk about your
solution how it can solve for a bunch of
these nist controls hit me up in the DMS
all right determine if essential
functions are defined essential
functions are defined by those functions
authorized to execute by and in this
case we're going to say Group Policy all
right because that's a great way to do
that uh and you know there's lots and
lots of ways okay lots of ways you can
have third-party programs that set up
what can and can't be installed uh Group
Policy security groups ous you name it
right all that stuff applies so hey and
on call we work with defense contractors
just like you who've had this defars
nist itar and cmmc compliant stuff
dropping their laps like a seagull on a
sunny day we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on-call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps great
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmccompliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliances roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign